first up he is the host of the podcast
mia couple with michael cohen and author
of the number one
new york times bestseller disloyal a
memoir the true story of the former
personal attorney
to president donald trump michael cohen
wow hey bill michael how are you
i'm doing okay how you doing bill okay
well you got a nice applause there from
our liberal crowd so you're off to a
good start very much um
it's good to be applauded all right i'll
bet uh but it is i
my first question is because i'm always
paranoid about prison
you know i watch prison shows it it that
doesn't look good and you were just in
prison
um so you're happy to be out i'm
guessing
uh you would be right about that yeah
and and you were in
otisville which is known as like a
jewish person i used to call it
unleavened worth
[Applause]
is that actually known as camp cupcake
yes i'm sorry i couldn't hear what you
say
i said it's it's also known as camp
cupcake it's um
you know we have tennis and we have
basketball and baseball
but it's still prison i don't want
anybody to think that
prison is fun you know being away from
my wife and my children and my friends
um it's very difficult especially 15
months
um it's it's not an easy it's not an
easy ride no matter where you're at
right and this country really needs to
start the country really needs to start
thinking about
better prison reform because i do know
the president talked about it
of course he put the secretary of
everything jared kushner on the job
so nothing's going to get done on there
either and you know um
we really do need prison reform in this
country desperately all right so and i i
look i know even the best president
you don't have your freedom and you're
you're cleaning toilets and
you know they they get up when they you
get up when they say get up and you know
it's prison it's it sucks my question to
you is because you're very honest in
your book
it's called mia culpa you know i mean
your show is called me a couple and your
book is
talking about you did bad things for
donald trump so i'm asking you right now
the punishment you had do you think it
was
too easy for what you did too hard
or just the right amount of punishment
you know it's that's a very tough
question it's a great question thank you
i think it was
it was i think it was just the right
amount i mean 15 months could be a way
one more day it would have been too much
well i did do 51 days in solitary
confinement
which is not easy you're locked in a
cell
that's eight by ten the windows were
broken it's 103 degrees
with no ventilation flies broken glass
the bath the bed toilets don't work
the sinks don't work you have no access
to the outside
for cold water it's not you're about
tennis and we had baseball and we had
it's uh
it sounded like a douche commercial and
then okay well
that was as a result that was as a
result of coding they put everybody into
solitary confinement all right so what
do you think
now you did some bad things for donald
trump i mean you
you paid off stormy daniels and if you
didn't do that we might have heard about
that before the election and he may not
be president so that's bad
and then you you say you threatened a
lot of people
what do you think is the what's the word
what do you feel worst about that you
did for trump
lie to melania you know about about all
this it's not my right
to have lied to her i shouldn't have
done it and it's something i feel
terrible about